bonjour je me présente Natacha Rioul
j'habite sur Saint-Pierre et je cherche
un poste de secrétaire midi ou social
j'ai le permis et j'ai mon véhicule j'ai
le titre de secrétaire assistante
médico-social que j'ai obtenu le 3
septembre dernier j'ai déjà travaillé en
tant que secrétaire médicale au centre
de gestion de Saint-Pierre j'ai aussi
travaillé à l'hôpital au CHU au service
gastrologie et aussi au centre
d'hébergement et de réinsertion sociale
sur Saint-Pierre toujours mes qualités
sont je suis discrète
organisées j'ai le sens de l'empathie
mes loisirs sont Internet et la course à
pied et je suis disponible de suite si
mon profil vous intéresse téléphonez moi